[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta que en esta ocasión nos
lleva a las Islas Canarias en España
donde luego volcán Cumbre vieja de la
isla de Palma había permanecido inactivo
durante medio siglo y de repente en
septiembre de 2021 entró en erupción
fuentes de llamas algunas de varias
decenas de metros de altura una nube
también de cenizas y luego flujos
imparables de lava que se deslizaban
lentamente montaña abajo hasta el Océano
Atlántico la erupción duró 85 días
destruyendo por completo más de mil
hogares también quedaron sumergidos 70
kilómetros de carreteras y 350 hectáreas
de plantaciones de plátano antes de la
erupción la mitad del producto interior
bruto de la isla procedía de los
plátanos cultivados para exportación el
corazón de la economía se vio gravemente
afectado No hubo víctimas mortales
gracias a las evacuaciones que
comenzaron en cuanto se emitieron las
primeras alertas al día siguiente de la
erupción el presidente del gobierno
español acudió al lugar pero a pesar de
estas garantías un año y medio después
las heridas en la isla de Palma siguen
abiertas un centenar de habitantes
actualmente siguen alojados en hoteles y
muchos aún esperan la ayuda prometida
por el gobierno el volcán se silenció
pero la ira en la población crece Esta
es la historia
[Música]
la palma más de un año después del final
de la erupción el cráter del volcán
Cumbre vieja sigue humeando
[Música]
para toda la India este fue el cráter
por el que salió la lava que arrasó toda
la laguna
el este centro de misión de aquí detrás
Es por donde salía la lava en las
últimas semanas de la erupción Lucía y
su marido Perdieron su casa sepultada
por la avalancha de lava en la reunión
estaban convocados los barrios de
hegeday por primera vez llegaron a ver
de cerca el origen del desastre
es como si fuese un que acabó con
todo lo que lo que había a mí se me
remueve todo lo que tengo dentro y los
recuerdos
han resurgido de nuevo
hoy su hija lidera la expedición ella
también estaba en Primera fila el día de
la erupción
hubo gente cuando yo salí de portonado
había gente que estaba todavía en el bar
de y era el ventilador que se estaba
moviendo pero como una cosa rarísima y
entonces se me encendió la luz y digo
ostras que son los terremotos que ya lo
siento
Me imagino que sí que evacuan te
limitaron un peso no podrás llevarte 14
mal entonces
y Tú metes lo que tú quieras que igual
no había tanta lava todavía o algo no sé
Cómo Saray y su familia 7.000 personas
huyeron para escapar del flujo de lava
extendido sobre 1200 hectáreas sepultó
todo a su paso
en esta casa en este piso no no sé dónde
están las cosas todavía mami los padres
de Saray fueron reubicados a unos 40
kilómetros del hogar de su hija y
recuerda un arrendamiento temporal
financiado en gran parte por el estado
Lucía Recuerda vívidamente la noche en
que perdió su casa
no tuvieron que decirme nada
se quedaron callados y yo sentí que algo
terrible pasaba Y esa noche
ya se llevó nuestra casa
unos días antes de esta noticia Lucía
había empezado a escribir un diario
ahora publicado
fue un modo de yo curarme de la del
miedo que provoca el que me provocaba el
volcán lava sobre lava sobre lava Así
que su prisa es llegar al Valle y otear
los márgenes explorar la orilla
inspeccionar la finca las casas que aún
resisten
más de mil familias han perdido sus
casas Es difícil para Alexis imaginar
que su antigua vida estaba aquí
Hoy está hundida bajo 50 metros de lava
mi casa estaría
Yo calculo esta era la zona industrial
estos pequeños
reductos que quedan aquí es muy duro
es sobrecogedor
pensar que todo lo que has trabajado
todo lo que han trabajado tus padres tus
abuelos
ya no existe
en pocos días la vida de Alexis y su
familia cambió
por la prisa no tuvo tiempo de reunir
todos los documentos de la casa lleva
seis meses intentando demostrar que era
el propietario con la esperanza de
recibir los 70.000 euros prometidos por
el estado
después de eso
un trozo de terreno
se ha multiplicado por 4 por 5 con lo
cual comprar un trozo de terreno y
construirte una casa como la que tenías
no sé en nuestro caso
hoy no lo podría hacer con
200.000 ni con 300.000 probablemente
el desastre no solo se llevó la casa de
Alexis aún le impide acceder a su
restaurante pues vamos en dirección a
Puerto Nao que es la zona que está ahora
mismo
evacuada no
Puerto náuse es una de las zonas
turísticas de La Isla ahora desierta
la zona se salvó de la lava pero las
autoridades la cerraron porque las
concentraciones de CO2 se consideraron
anormalmente altas
[Aplausos]
al final de esta calle Alexis aún puede
ver su pizzería solo se le permite
entrar una vez cada dos meses
venimos a diferentes puntos y hacemos
lecturas y luego lo contrastamos con las
lecturas que nos dan desde las
administraciones es posible que hayan
gases lo que sí estamos seguros es que
no existe la misma concentración de
gases en todo Puerto nau en toda el área
de la misma manera No desde el desastre
Alexis ha estado Sobreviviendo gracias a
un subsidio de desempleo temporal Espera
que las autoridades le permitan
reincorporarse rápidamente al trabajo
nos sentimos abandonados nos sentimos
engañados nos sentimos excluidos y
sentimos que la administración que nos
está representando en realidad no nos
está representando nos está perjudicando
en la isla las víctimas de la catástrofe
se han reunido en asociaciones
esta noche Alexis se reúne con sus
representantes buenas Cómo están bien
bueno su misión es mantener la presión
sobre los poderes públicos
hasta el final hasta donde tengamos que
llegar llegaremos la gente fuera del
lugar fuera de la isla de la palma no
conoce la situación piensa que ya
estamos bien piensa que ya nos han dado
todo lo que nos tenían que dar no no
aquí queda mucho que hacer
incluso
empeorado
ha empeorado porque
aparte del turismo la principal fuente
de ingresos de la palma es el cultivo
del banano que representa el 50% del pib
de La Isla
estas plantaciones en Terrazas prosperan
en este clima templado
el flujo del agua partió en dos la
principal zona de producción de La Isla
[Música]
esto sería un racimo muy probable que
sea un racimo de agosto del año 21
entonces entiende o intenta imaginar que
que en agosto del año 21 nosotros
teníamos un racimo de Aproximadamente 40
kilos que lo recolectaríamos A lo mejor
en diciembre o enero y ahora tenemos una
planta pequeña que tardará ya en torno a
diez meses en tener un racimo
desde hace varias generaciones la
familia de Ricardo vive del cultivo del
banano
esta
misma la ves aquí la rey Entonces lo que
tenemos que hacer es
intentar tenerlas lo más cubiertas
posibles para la humedad
y ya se van poniendo bonitas
y yo creo que si todo marcha en julio
agosto podemos tener una piña aquí
para comunicarse entre las dos zonas de
producción Ricardo toma esta Nueva
carretera construida sobre la avalancha
aquí alcanza los 70 metros de
profundidad en algunos puntos
lo duro es que tú pasas conduciendo
prácticamente por encima de tu casa de
la casa de tu gente de tu familia de tus
amigos es difícil ya le ya comentaba que
es como como invadir su espacio es como
si estuviese en el salón de tu casa
viendo la tele y ahora de repente hay
gente pasando con un coche por dentro
continuamente
en mayor o menor grado muchos de los
habitantes de la isla están
traumatizados los agricultores están
entre los más afectados
como tal hombre
en la foto posiblemente a lo mejor no se
llegue a cortar sí la fruta si la noto
yo como Sí deshidratada así entonces
aparte de eso que otra cosecha más que
has preparado para volverla a perder
sería la segunda cosecha que perdemos
la erupción daño la infraestructura
hidráulica de La Isla reduciendo la
cantidad de agua disponible para el
riego
yo personalmente Me siento vacío
completo por dentro Muchas veces ni
ganas de trabajar ni ganas de hacer nada
porque
ya no veo tanto lo que he pasado lo que
he pasado Ya está he vivido pero es que
miro y sigo viendo
más oscuro lo que veo miro para adelante
creo que miro para atrás cualquier cosa
que vayas a comprar hoy en día valen
cuatro veces lo que valían antes
No yo no quito datos desanimados
Victoria y Ricardo ya no saben Cómo
afrontar el futuro
días después de llegar el volcán yo
confiaba plenamente en que yo no iba a
vivir lo que he pasado este año confiaba
en Europa confiaba en los políticos en
la administración y la realidad es esta
ha pasado un montón de tiempo nos han
hecho pasar un montón de trabajos nos
han hecho endeudarnos han conseguido que
tengamos que tirar de ahorro no llegue
al dinero cuando llega es poco y tarde y
mal Ah vale y nada Víctor Pues aquí en
total la erupción arrasó las casas de
más de mil familias todavía hay 100
personas en hoteles y más de 100
familias viviendo en estas casas
prefabricadas
[Música]
algunos de ellos están trasladando ahora
a esta nueva zona
36 casas Rurales construidas por el
gobierno canario
bien bastante bien sí me enseñas tu casa
claro pasa la casa de Carmen fue una de
las primeras en ser derribadas por la
corriente de lava
el salón comedor durante más de un año
su familia estuvo alojada en un albergue
la ropa
aquí pues lo que hemos ido comprando
Durante este año
solo cogimos a los animalitos mi nieto
mis hijos y fuera a las 2:30 de la tarde
y el volcán rever en todas las tres a
las tres y dar gracias que no pasó nada
gracias a las donaciones y a una
subvención Estatal de 17.000 euros
Carmen pudo amueblar su Nuevo Hogar
Pues con los hemos comprado pues esto
todo lo que ven todo lo que ven porque
nosotros Hemos salido sin nada
No hemos tenido tiempo a nada
ahora me van a traer
las mesas los sillones Pues todos los
muebles lo que conlleva la casa Es que
llevo un año que para mí se queda y
ahora verme otra vez con las llaves de
mi casa en la mano es que no te lo puedo
explicar
no te lo puedo explicar
La amenaza del volcán Aún se cierne
sobre estos habitantes
cada semana este grupo de científicos
viene a controlar su actividad
lo dejamos por aquí Juan
tenemos que dar digamos la vuelta a todo
el edificio volcánico para empezar desde
un sitio donde no haya emisiones que
queremos observar y dar la vuelta entera
para empezar a ver esa como sube esa
concentración en este caso del dióxido
de azufre
las concentraciones de azufre medidas
por el tron son la prueba de que el
volcán sigue activo
en total la erupción creó seis nuevos
cráteres
cerca de 85.000 toneladas de dióxido de
azufre se liberaban diariamente en el
punto álgido de la catástrofe ahora
estamos pasando por la zona norte y
tenemos un pico en esta zona que empieza
a aumentar aquí la concentración
justamente pasando por el norte del
bueno noroeste del edificio volcánico
hace un año Víctor formaba parte del
grupo de vigilancia del volcán
sabe que la isla de la palma
experimentará otras erupciones
en la última erupción fue en el 1971
aquí en la palma y había una
probabilidad de un 50% que en 50 años
hubiese una erupción
pasaron 50 años en el 2021 y casualmente
vino esta esta erupción cuando no
sabemos si dos años cuatro años cinco
años 20 años pero va a verla tanto aquí
en la palma en el hierro y tenerife
un año después de la catástrofe la isla
de la palma sigue luchando por
recuperarse
los daños causados por el volcán
ascienden a casi mil millones de euros
los habitantes deben seguir viviendo con
La amenaza de la próxima catástrofe
la única incógnita
es cuando ocurrirá
[Música]
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta que en esta
oportunidad nos llevó a las Islas
Canarias en España visitamos la isla de
Palma después de la erupción del volcán
Cumbre vieja donde tendrán muchos años
difíciles de reconstrucción
obstaculizados por el calor magmático
que persiste y también un futuro
económico incierto recuerde que puede
Ingresar a nuestra página web
para ver esta emisión y las anteriores
Hasta pronto
[Música]